[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bon choix le monde
entier comment il est si ça devait bien
moins mais mieux
alors aujourd'hui on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge mais où on est à trois bassins
qu'est ce qu'il y à trois bassins bayer
trois bassins non mais c'est un
déconneur
en fait le noir jean-noël jean noël
il fait quoi s'ils me disent oh non me
fait l'ailé l'ale lll et non je ne
regrette rien
oui aujourd'hui on va voir un fabricant
de kayamb bien sûr sans faux sur la
réunion thanou tradition et l'ami monde
même mais montrent tout temps d'en faire
la cote du monte mes mouvements
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a mis nos frontières soient venir
quelqu'un est maintenant viables
comment il est bonjour la forme à
belfort montfort super coûte déjà merci
d'accueillir notre case ben c'est moi
c'est marion mais c'est la dbv nié
s'être bassin voit pas fait à lasser la
case des annuelles passées on fabrique
savons fabriqués tous tassement et
musiques traditionnelles l'île de la
réunion n'est pas bon de kayes on me
connaît pas mon cas y entre on est bien
d'accord à bécaye en moins et ça il
n'existe pas ça n'existe pas ça caille
en gros caillou me met dehors non plus
ça ici à la gayonne traditionnel trail
des traditionnels avec 6,6 ou cana ou
simplement dans les mailles du coût de
sa zone mais coûte me reconnais qu'on me
proposait aux mains oui notamment tout
ça un des problèmes est votre problème
ben on a vraiment un petit peu le monde
était l'atelier samifin que le camion à
londres
[Musique]
alors ça c'est quoi ça c'est la
carnation canne à sucre les fleurs
l'anglais c'est la ti de la carnation de
flottant à la fée fée town
voilà pourquoi on sait pour avoir les
cailloux pour avancer il faut savoir
savoir connaître comment s'est déployée
tutoyer comme ça jamais rien à faire est
ce que on en a un
est-ce qu'on a un moment précis pouls de
de couper le bon tige ou halo ou alors
dès que le bâton comment se lever avec
le bouquet en l'air ou coup pallier le
bon ben là pour les récupère ça dans le
sang il faut être concédée à couper que
c'est la terre avant le taxi passe de 6
kral parce que c'est l'état qui perd pas
décidé la caraïbe dans une fillette
s'est finie avant comment se fait à
faire là seront admises et contrit entre
le moyen ou mais avec moins le trio met
les pieds comme ça tout ça sera fini on
était allé caillan minutes il y aura sa
les dents ça qui était vous voyez là bas
alors ça c'est saas nous ici audi sal
cana
c'est ça qu'on met dedans après si vous
avez passé à la danse c'est pas la peine
ça va ça va ça va pas faire du bruit et
n'a pas à pas grand complot donc oui il
peut m
dans le camion bon on y pense que le
meilleur même s'il y met moins mal à te
je connais pas ce qu'il veut quand même
en amont avant d'emmener les outres les
balmanais beaucoup les décès d'el pilar
mais bonne chance hier à oran est ok ça
si à pasadena brett hayes en cause un
bouton et cause la passivité et aussi
nous ont fait le caillou pour surfer par
camion pour découvrir exactement la
cession ou visionner les sondages alors
que noël ça c'est le saas et le calme le
cadre ça c'est ça c'est les cas c'est
déjà un peu parlé avant d'accord voilà
les tees et l'a donc en fait si me
comprends bien le kayamb il a donc tout
autour à une maison de fous de cannes
voilà et à l'intérieur on aura le grand
bal a relaté hier que s'apprête à fermer
sinon on va même mètres mais le grain
des dents comme le vainqueur est chiche
demain cascade
[Musique]
un type comme à là il faut combien de
temps pour faire moi même
un petit comme ça même pas disons un
canadien demande ça va renault fait dan
dans les alentours ou alors voyage un
peu plus souvent un peu plus un peu
pardon lille bat pas de plus loin c'est
plutôt salubres sein de ba les
agriculteurs jouent le jeu ben oui on
est habitué des critères se parle des
périodes de la coupe bâtisse et des arcs
ou chamonix rodez il faut pas trop tôt
en finance et parce que sinon ça va
abîmer sera rasée
m
[Musique]
arrêt grand flou est facile à trouver ou
même parce que la même période pour
gonfler à pour denain période pour la
can la calebasse et le conflent il
commencé avant il va dès mai mezyan
comédiens prépare là comme ça les
nourrit d'un confort et noir bas et
après mois d'août mais d'autres
médailles pu ramasser les inconforts
comment ça va ya ramassé la tiens voilà
bon dans les camps même l'apcm prenez
pas ça c'est le premier papier
maintenant on va passer
m
[Musique]
alors ça c'est le conflent conflent là
vous voyez les petites poches comme ça
mais c'est là dedans en fête qui aura
ses grains là c'est bien sa vie c'est
celle ci mais ça et ça ne passait là les
locaux vers l'allée en convient les
blancs lavalas les blancs la cob non
encore ouverts et après quand il sera à
sec que sera noir le bras c'est comme ça
voilà comme ça comme ça ensuite la
quantité de 20 par rapport à au caillou
ou pas bousiller tout secret parce que
bon il faut pas dire tout secret non
plus belle était toutefois de toute
façon le secret bien s améliorera par le
monte d'oro bien au moins le suppose
qu'il est important la quantité de gras
qu'on met dedans ça alors là comme
entité qui m'adorent à la volée même tu
viens de rome voilà un petit bla de rome
non mais on met un média un média comme
ça ici pendant l'été note ici ici
après ensuite pour remettre une note
avant cela c'est la moitié moitié moitié
et la moitié maintenant on ferme ferme
la maison d'allah
[Musique]
on l'exécuté bettencourt
d'accord pour mettre là dessus comme ça
ces pouvoirs locaux pour casser pour que
cet événement les couleurs
[Musique]
des consoles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors je précise messieurs dames et
jeunes gens que le rouleur c'est aussi
jean-noël grande mais voilà et l'a donc
voilà les différentes formes de radoub
n'ayant mis à la vente des différents
différentes dimensions pardon comme
brizio est ce que fait des cayes sommes
plus grands que celle là ça c'est la
taille idéale s'activent en plus c'est
cette faille là après le plus grand mais
travaille plutôt sur comment ça allait
vraiment joli mais comme je dis bravo
merci
j'applaudis c'est ma v5 main mes
tableaux du 7 mars
[Musique]
les voix lui bien avec moi sur scène
comment on l'a décidé de fait
qu'ailleurs mais ce que petit ou pas
était déjà dans cabaret aux côtés de
malouda ou jouez déjà caillan mois lors
l'arrivée un moment donné du jour au
lendemain comme cela dit aimer sa
fabrication basque a noté m le 100e
nation l'occaion à fait comme les autres
personnes étaient 6000 et pourquoi pas
aimé ça y était aussi mais c'était pas
été pas facile on m'a montré comment
comment il savait comment il gère pour
la commencer ce petit caillou avec d'un
ultime aucunement d'un mauvais
dégagement de les mettre en super g dans
les données d'un petit prix
et après mon avec la personne qui me l'a
pour y fabriquer ça il y avait daniel
waro il faut pas oublier voilà voilà
et après un petit peu tu peux aussi
bonne a mené l'équipe et aussi parce que
ça lui dit pas autre fait bien tel wi fi
rouleurs que kai hom après huit ans et
en chine continentale au travail le
stress va quoi revoilà aussi donc du
commandant la main là dans chaque doigt
90 à l'audio voilà ben écoute mais
croire que m'a fait le tour de tous
on a fait le toit non je crois mais
coûte mimer messager ou tout simplement
revoir
ben moi c'est pareil romans et ses
promesses et à zola et des médias c'est
de savoir écouter comment laver à dire
mais on en a mais c'est tout le monde
peut nous donner avec nous c'est notre
alors ces localités automatiquement
automatiquement faut que tous les gens
de la réunion est d'ailleurs il faut il
faisait ya trois c'est quoi il fait
notre histoire aussi notre histoire
culturelle et musicale donc d'être est
important que des gens comme nous n'en a
encore pour prendre tout ça voilà tout
simplement merci beaucoup elle a
remercié mois que ces macarons mais
aussi la zone et puis ben à la prochaine
adhésion à la possèdent les bons à la
préfère aller vous retrouve à la
nouveauté ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà messieurs dames
l'émission se termine mais ne pleurez
pas je reviendrai bientôt promis juré
je vous quitte avec une magnifique vue
de la saline regardez-le ailleurs encore
des flottes cannes quoi jean noël pour
ses jolis cailloux et on remarque aussi
que la coupe a commencé parce qu'il ya
une bonne partie qui a été coupée je
vous dis tout simplement aurevoir à la
prochaine ne pleurez pas je reviendrai
promis juré et on n'est pas du tout
sorti de l'auberge mais alors pas du
tout moi je vais là-bas
[Musique]